so we went through some tests we first
figured out I had something called
c-diff right an overgrowth of a
unfriendly bacteria right and everyone
has see death to a certain extent it's a
I mean it's a bacteria but can you talk
a little bit about that it might be more
probably appropriate for told me to talk
about it but I think yes you're right
it's there in everybody's got but when
something goes wrong and you lose the
other key players then this bad guy has
the opportunity to open great you think
that's fair Tommy Johnny yeah that's
exactly it so when people talk about
what's going on in the gut and the bugs
in the gut the gut microbiota whatever
you want to call it there's often it's
often characterized as these are good
and these are bad but that's never the
case in medicine or biology right sadly
it's just not that simple
however when you have an imbalance so
you have too much of one versus and not
enough and other that's usually how they
come together then you're gonna you're
gonna see some issues and CDF is a
common one particularly now with the use
of antibiotics so if you take
particularly broad-spectrum antibiotics
or antibiotics that target a lot of
different bacteria then you sort of
clean out a lot of some of what's going
on in the gut and most of its good and
then some of these other guys can they
grow to fill the niche that's been left
by those other bugs you've killed with
the antibiotics and CDF is one
particularly particularly in hospitals
particularly in older people not that
I'm calling old but that's that's where
we see them where we see it most
frequently and it can be
life-threatening actually an overgrowth
of c-diff but we see a very frequent
frequently in our clients who for
various reasons there's some kind of
imbalance going on and then then it can
cause issues so that's exactly what was
happening with you that's absolutely in
the thing is I for the almost the
previous decade so I had really bad
scalp acne which is probably the best
place to have acne because if you have
hair it covers it up right and so I'm
like uh it was actually a soy allergy I
didn't know that for for many years but
like if I eat some stuff like eats a
piece of tofu I get a huge outbreak on
my head right and so I didn't realize
the time and so I went to a dermatology
and he's like yeah back tren it's this
antibody you just take it every single
day it's benign I'm like oh the doctor
said the antibiotics benign so I'm
taking this antibody every day for
nearly a decade and it totally destroyed
my gut it was it was right around that
it was shortly before my mother died my
marriage inside these two traumatic
events I also worked in retail and we
were remodeling all of these stores
right around the same time so I was
exposed to all these crazy chemicals
that were going on so I I mean I open
dozens of retail stores and I was there
you know with the hard hats and
everything and and making sure everyone
was doing their job so I was exposed to
all these chemicals I'm doing this
intense antibiotic treatment and plus
anytime I got a cold what did I do I
went and got a z-pack or whatever and
they just take the antibiotics and
you'll be fine I totally destroyed my
guy now I write around 27 and then
beyond I just started having all these
gut issues which through through this
testing which by the way when you first
started sending me these tests it's not
like it's just one test right I mean my
my kitchen was just filled with piss and
[ __ ] and I mean it was like you've got
these little stool things and you're
peeing on things you're spitting and
vials and you're peeing on these strips
but this was important in figuring out
like in the interesting thing is I think
out of the first six or seven tests that
we did a lot of them came back sort of
I'll say inconclusive you're like right
there there's a whole lot to do with
this here and then all of a sudden we
got the six or seventh one back here
like oh here's the c-diff thing and then
from there you recommended doing some
stuff with supplementation and with my
diet that would change that and I
remember talking about leaky gut as well
is that something that we should talk
about at this point sure all right let's
do it yes important problem so it's it's
actually a really interesting problem
because it's not really accepted in the
regular medical community and and there
are a few things that sort of exists in
the fringe health sphere which we
occasionally inhabit but I want to be
really clear that the reason I was so
attracted to what you guys were talking
about is
it you you you may have liked you dip a
toe into the eastern world but only if
there's like like evidence exactly it's
not just like well here yeah just if
first call Chris would have been like
yeah just rubbed this crystal against
your face three times a day like it even
as desperate as I was for answers I
think I would have said yeah thank you
very much have a nice day all right the
next phase so you're right one of the
benefits of not being in a rigid
formalized medical system which we're
not is that you can you can change and
adapt and adopt things as they become
more evidence-based and that's something
you know leaky gut is certainly one of
those things some people might call it
intestinal permeability and there's
plenty of evidence to show that people
with various autoimmune diseases even
metabolic diseases type 2 diabetes if
you take a piece of their gut and you
look at it there's for want of a better
word there's holes in it there's meant
to be connections between the cells and
the guts that stop things that you don't
want coming across coming across and
there are many things that can can
affect that and it can be foods you're
intolerant to it could be certain toxic
things you're exposed to one thing that
c-diff does is it makes a toxin which
breaks down or you know causes some of
those junctions to be broken down so
that results in a leaky gut or some
degree of intestinal permeability and
then what happens is either things that
new parts of the bacteria so bacteria
they're there they do good stuff for us
but they do also contain some things
that can be toxic
those have easier access to your body
other things that you're eating that
maybe you don't want to get into your
bloodstream until you've fully digested
them they're getting across early that
can also cause issues so whatever the
initial cause is and there can be many
then all of a sudden you have this whole
host of symptoms and this is one of
those things where you're talking about
how the whole body is connected and
often it's at least part of that is
connected through the gut so something
that we see certainly very frequently in
our
in our clients the people that we work
with and this is one of the downsides of
the way modern medicine has structured
which is that everybody separated by a
body part right so you have a
neurologist who only looks at your brain
and you have a hepatologist or who only
looks at your liver and you know you
have an ophthalmologist well only look
at your eyes except for the fact that
all of these things are connected by a
blood stream and all these other things
that are happening in the body at the
same time the hormone signaling covers
the whole body so when we sort of
separate our body parts we don't look at
the big picture as often and I think
that's where that's where we hopefully
can can start to piece things together
and and often as was the case with you
it sort of can stem with some kind of
large exposure or something that's going
on inside inside the guts well I think
that that's one of the big problems
because when I went to doctors and they
said here's an inhaler or you're just
depressed and let me prescribe some
Nordahl or something and I I'm against
sort of antidepressants unless I think
they're absolutely necessary I think we
suffer from a lot of sadness and we
often categorized it as depression and
we try to just give someone the medicine
when there's a whole bunch of other like
sort of real medicine that will will
work better like exercise and sunlight
and water right people use try these
things as well but I remember going to a
GI doctor who's like just the because my
in my early 30s as my gut problems got
worse I'm like how could a GI doctor
he's like yeah it just takes a Metamucil
for the rest of your life and you'll be
fine and I mean that's the other main
reason I started the business was as an
engineer I recognized that there was
absolutely zero attempts to see what was
going wrong there was no root cause
analysis like it's obviously a complex
system and I can see that you spent
exactly zero minutes trying to figure
out what's causing this problem so for
the example of your scalp acne they
didn't spend a lot of time trying to
investigate whether or not it was a food
sensitivity that was causing that
problem I'm just gonna jump straight to
a solution I just happened to have right
here in my desk drawer yeah right and of
course this does doesn't work it doesn't
work in health it doesn't work anywhere
else either so for example when I'm
riding a bicycle and I get a flat tire
if I just shove another tube in there
and pump it up the chances are it's
gonna go flat again because the thorn is
still stuck in the title whatever
punctured the tube is still there you
have to find out why the tire went flat
before you put a new tube in and for
some reason in medicine they don't do
that they just jumped straight to the to
the solution which in my opinion doesn't
work right right and and because often
the solution is is figuring out what the
problem actually is right and and and
for me it was okay I'm having these gut
problems but it's not just like all of a
sudden your guts gone bad it's that
there's something that's underlying it
one was like hey no more antibiotics and
less absolutely necessary and don't get
me wrong I'm not an anti I'm not an anti
antibiotic guy what's an anti antibody a
biotic guy but I'm all for them when
appropriate right it's just we've been
using them inappropriately in fact one
of the words I use when people we talk
about minimalism and that word scares
people then I say okay just use the word
appropriate like maybe it's appropriate
ism like because what's appropriate for
your life may not be appropriate for
mine with respect to the material
possessions that we own and by the way
when I first found minimalism I was 28
years old and I'll be 37 this week so
it's almost a decade later what was
appropriate then is it appropriate now
I've got a five year old daughter like
my life is different and it's it's true
with each of our our our diets in our
health I think there are some
overarching principles that make a lot
of sense but then what really helped me
is is when we chatted you got down to
the granular level and and you we said
okay here are some tests that are
appropriate
you